welcome everyone to the Whitney and
Betty macmillan international center for
international area studies at Yale im
sue Stokes I teach in the political
science department and I direct the yet
program on democracy Ian Shapiro the
director of the Macmillan Center can't
be here this evening or at this point
because he's teaching a class which is a
good excuse and he he sorry not to be
here at the outset we are delighted to
host David Mayhew as this year's Henry L
Stimson lecturer David is sterling
professor emeritus of political science
at Yale he is a leading scholar in
American politics he's written numerous
books about Congress political parties
elections and policymaking his books
include Congress the electoral
connection divided we govern America's
Congress electoral realignments parties
and policies partisan balance and
placing parties the parties in American
politics he's a fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Science a member of
the American Philosophical society and
in 2013 he was elected to the National
Academy of Sciences he's also been a
recipient of the James Madison and
Samuel elders fell de wardes for career
contributions and on top of that I'm
sure almost everyone in this room knows
that David happens to be an enormously
generous teacher and colleague and just
a lovely human being David's going to
give a series of lectures on the imprint
of Congress his new book that's going to
be published with yale university press
the lectures will focus on three themes
the imprint of Congress how to think
about it which is tonight's lecture the
history which which he'll talk about
tomorrow and an assessment for for next
Tuesday September 29th the Stimson
lectures are sponsored by the Macmillan
Center and Yale University Press they're
funded by an anonymous donor in honor of
Henry and L Stimson VL college class of
1889 Henry Stimson was an attorney
and statesmen whose government service
culminated with his tenure as Secretary
of War during World War two previous
Stimson lectures have included political
order in changing societies by Samuel
Huntington arms and influenced by Thomas
Schelling the Arab center the promise of
moderation by ambassador Marwan washer
beyond the Democratic maze by John Donne
and what happened to national liberation
by Michael Walzer I'm delighted to
introduce David Mayhew all right thanks
very much so either the title I want to
talk about the imprint of Congress and
today how to think about it and my
question is what what has been
Congress's imprint I chose in the down
skip ways I can on American society in
life I want to arrest them with that
question here and as suicide a short
book will come out of it this mic
working okay all right and it's a tough
question I think but it's an interesting
question and an important question and
today what I want to do is to lay out
some rules of analysis and invite you to
go along it's it's there it is this is
you know a complicated structure that
I'm building here now I want to say this
is a it's a distinctive question what is
the imprint of Congress I want to say
there's a there's a list of alternative
questions that I'm not asking here want
to tell you what I'm not doing for
openers I learn press this thing yeah
there's a literature for example has
congressman democratic or representative
enough that has some distinguished
offerings it in a book by Bob doll
recently a book by Sandy Levinson that's
not my question arts internal processes
any good probably that's a fetched more
political scientists into appraising
Congress over the decades at any other
question that's not my question either a
pretty much I'm going to ignore
internal processes is it good at passing
White House proposals that's also
there's also a literature there it's a
denominator literature as the White
House sends up the numerator we figure
out is that the way it goes you know no
no White House says if a denominator and
then we see what Congress would spring
for as stuff that actually passes
literature there another very commonly
asked question is have Americans in
general like the way Congress performs
and the answer to that is a very
resounding no generally speaking
Americans don't like the way Congress
performs i order that's true with
Congress's in other countries or
legislators in other countries let go
sometimes they've been referred to as
talking shops in Europe for example but
any Wes there's public opinion studies
which are rapidly sometimes asked this
question or one of a family of questions
looking for such appraisals by people
out there go back about 80 years back to
the mid 1940s and you look at it I stay
at the data there's a small verdict
really good literature and sometimes
series it's a bit of a problem because
the questions keep changing a little bit
this is a certain lack of constancy when
you go back a ways the general picture
though is it a low average and people
say they like the way Congress operates
going way to be back there's a great
deal of volatility in the readings over
time what the public tends to like is a
binge of collective consensual
activities such as happened in capitol
hill in 2001 2002 after 911 when they
passed the Patriot Act when they agreed
to the exercise in Afghanistan that'll
give you high ratings or the mid 1960s
when the enactment of the civil rights
act of 64 thanks in 1765 that was very
very popular acclaimed activity which is
not exactly consensual on Capitol Hill
was done by big majorities there but you
take over the 80 years and though they
some reading readings lately in below
and one of the
questions is Congress doing a good job
questions like that I think you look
over the 80 years there's no sloop
there's no slope in answers to that
questions down but that you want to take
to the bank it's son really it's a it's
it's ragged but but generally speaking
there are a lot of seller answers
sellers eell a our answers sort of to
the question this Congress they approved
the way Congress is operating another
question which is not mine is tap
American intellectuals like the way
Congress performs and their run the
answer is now also amid the American
electoral have not been fans of the
performance of the Congress then various
right is one of the largest literature's
in political science also it's a well
represented literature in journalism
it's let's call it as a critique
literature that goes back a long ways
this is initiated by the first big move
and it was by woodrow wilson later the
president it is booked in eighteen
eighty five congressional government
who's read that besides me is it so bang
read we've drawer wilson congressional
government Joey I must have read it at
some time of course he did of course he
did this this is one of the founding
texts of American political science i
think congress has probably been studied
more by political scientists and any
other American governmental institution
and Wilson's book about Congress
congressional jet government was
basically a trash job that is it was
it's our Congress says I went through
and picked out the points he made the
arguments he saw Congress particularly
the house of representatives as
obstructionist opaque particular istic
unaccountable meddlesome into the
administration which was trying to do
things very poor debate prone to board
policies and quote serve I'll and quote
to the quote wins quote of popular
constituencies end quote it was a trash
job and that's a good news it's real it
was at that kind of a book and it's its
passage and it's a good book by the way
it's an interesting book this is a smart
man you can see well I don't know if
smart this is that much of a
qualification for the
you could see how he succeeded in public
life the Woodrow Wilson it's very nice
start to the study of Congress into a
lifetime career north o lifetime as a
scholar and in my lifetime which goes
back to the late 1930s my sentient life
time goes back to the about nineteen
fifty or so it's um that's up there
there's a line of book titles which is
indicative this is by political
scientists or journalists about commerce
or mostly about Congress Congress at the
crossroads 1947 Congress on trial that
was on trial in 1949 this is done by Jan
to Gregor birds the deadlock at
democracy obstacle course a plus
Congress in crisis the American Way
politics at the breaking point you can
read this fight club politics the broken
branch all the way through you just have
to read the titles you don't even need
the author's this was some this these
readings brought into very prominence
prominence the the inertia criticism
that as Congress doesn't do anything it
sits there it should be doing things and
it sits there when I went through
bernsen's book this 1949 in Congress and
trial very smart book by the way
Congress on trial a bit I bet jaws read
that once it with you it's so and picked
out his metaphors for what was going on
on Capitol Hill and here's a list of his
metaphors stalled stymied stalemate in
action in earnest obstructionism stasis
roadblock deadlock these are terms that
decorate the book and today we'd say
gridlock that's become a fashionable
turret going back about two or three
decades gridlock sometimes a logjam in
this sub NS literature in a critique
literature is a little bit of a pause
here another a theme besides inertia a
nursery and the recent literature is so
is his decline ISM that it decline ISM
those things once we're better maybe you
already see that in Woodrow Wilson's
book in eighteen eighty five I mean
looking back at the previous history of
the separation of power system in
Congress within it there's a slump
downwards in the waiting
tuition is operating and we see that in
our own time said sometimes the Senate
of the 1950s is looked back as the kind
of Golden Age by us now it's the book by
the 2006 book the broken branch by Tom
Mann and normal NC and some of their
terms about what happened recent
abandonment decline demise collapse are
some of the metaphors that they throw
around in that book and maybe they're
all true you know maybe maybe you can
disprove the allegation of a slope that
goes down for 150 years I mean it may be
may be some truth in it but I want to
report what's being said in the works
the term dysfunction has become an
umbrella term today dysfunction in DC
not just on capital or entailing capital
bill but certainly entailing principally
a Capitol Hill now I want to one so I
brought this up because it's very
prominent literature in it and index is
a very prominent way of thinking I but I
I sidestep this critique this critique
literature and this these talks and in
this upcoming book for three reasons one
is that it tends to it being a headlines
sort of thing that is it tends to tookie
unto what went on last week or during
the last year on Capitol Hill that's
number one the second reason I'm
sidestepping is that it has it tends to
have a pretty heavy dose of partisan
super ideology that goes into it as
looking in the background right often as
somebody is unhappy with the policies
that have come out and they're given as
a consequence or related to the
unhappiness of the Polly's coming out
with a diagnosis that the system isn't
any good that's a very dark very
cognizant Wilson sorry dish they go back
and read critically I'd like to write a
review without Wilson well the winter
well said book and I 1885 what was what
was what was his inch and I pee on it
it's one of his interest was Wilson was
a southern Democrat it was a Dixiecrat
he's sitting there at night 1885 in the
Johns Hopkins library and he didn't like
what does Republican Congress's were
doing he didn't like the civil rights
activity didn't like the tariff didn't
like the pork barrel a lot off Lottie
didn't like and he
it turned this flower rather he under
pendants it's like or elaborated dislike
with a diagnosis that the system was no
good that is the separation of power
system itself and the operations kagu
stood and in which he detailed the
operations he did and in my lifetime mm
did the inertia literature that is
connected that's very much other
democratic and liberal side going back
to the 19th late 1930s and 40s that is
the democrats and liberals were
chronically not always tend to be
disappointed with the policies that
bubbling out of Congress year after year
decade after not always but very often
they're unhappy and it's a short step
from there to the statement my party
can't get it what at one so the system
must be broken and you just has to be
careful you have to read critically you
have to think when you come across
allegations that the system is broken
there we are that's reason number two
that i sidestepped but the third reason
and the chief reason that i sidestepped
this critical literature is that I want
to try to examine a different terrain as
I want to look at the I want to the
cryptic literature it hinges on or is it
fast fast and signs of aspirations
policy aspirations what could be done
ought to be done on two processes the
filibuster and such now that and onto
optics things look terrible in DC
aspirations processes optics are
constant concerns in the critique
literature but what I what I want to
will fasten onto something different and
want to try to look at rather the
effects or the results of congressional
activity the effects are the results
hence the reach for the term in print
it's a it's a consequentialist
consequentialist exercise that I'm
undertaking here which can by the way
you can lead to like economics in the
old days which used to be called the
dismal science once it was anyway
regarder in those days a
consequentialist taken can bring you a
lot of dismal nosome a no realities are
less pleasant than aspirations generally
speaking but what I want to look at is
somehow realities at results as I say
results
facts there and to this end I had to
take I had to take an investigation into
a deep american history that it's back
to the beginning back to 1789 which
means now two in one quarter centuries
during which Congress has been operative
and what I'm going to do is going to be
interpreted it's going to be speculative
it's going to be pro see what I'm what
I'm going to try it so it's all it's
also the past that is it's so deep
earthy and auxiliary verbs and come up
or groups that come up a very often has
been or was rather than is or will be
that is what inferences he might be
drawn from 225 years after all or unsure
going into and today it for today are
going into the future that's the way it
is but nonetheless the ways that
institutions carry on do I really have a
lot of continuity so it's not pointless
I think to look at away the institution
it's a long one Purcell Mumbai the
weight or not that many political
institutions in the world have been
operating with reasonable success that
long we could make a less we could get
the you know the Roman Curia the british
house of commons or not that many
they've been operating with reasonable
says what's that it survived that's at
least an indicator of reasonable success
all right now what has been Congress's
distinctive imprint I mean on such
matters as the launching of the nation
and the 1790s building a welfare state
the coming of neoliberalism around
nineteen eighty or so 1970s and 1980s
these are out big things that happen i'm
going to give you in a few minutes a
chart of 13 big patches of things that
have happened that i want to take a look
at starting way back there i want to say
that I I got into this project by by
doing a lot of reading it's so how did I
can end this project by
doing a lot of reading commonly I do a
letter ring also I'd gotten I got no I
didn't want to do the kind of writing
political science writing about Congress
that I'd done in the past it's it's no
point doing the same thing over and over
again or trying to it seems to be I want
to try something a little different I
was tired I guess particularly of a
summary summary roll called statistics
that are being used to show or diagnose
or indicate what's happened in
congressional or American history I
don't think that works very well I mean
as I as that application of numbers to
the history it goes I don't think it
goes all that well I wanted to but
mostly I think it comes from I get here
this a result of as a result of reading
and finding things it's it's not in the
in the end they it's directed to on any
particular project I was going as I was
going into it but rather is through
canvassing for writings about various
things but including Congress that keep
coming out articles books journal
articles books keep coming out and take
a look and see what's being sent there
and what I'm doing here I think could
not have been done 40 years ago or at
least if it hadn't done 40 years ago it
would have been done very differently
and that's speaking partly because we
have 40 more years of experience
actually that is about one sixth of
American history right there during the
last 40 years isn't it but that's been
I'm impressed from reading history how
much the writing of history continues
two flrs there's so much of it and so
much if it's so good the writing of I'm
here particularly American history it's
it's you have to reach out to it see
most of the history that i got into and
that I draw on here it wasn't what
hasn't been principally about Congress
but a lot a lot of efforts historic
Ithorian efforts pick up in some way
Congress they get into Congress some way
Congress's
separate American political life in some
respect so if you do a policy history
likely to hit Congress and some policy
area for example or if aesthetic fire
relations you know you likely did
Congress at some point if so I mean I 11
know I came to like for one thing
reading economic history is I think of
economic history it's one of the most
high-powered literature's out there and
I think all the political sciences
should read economic history it's so
illuminating or it can be about what's
going on in politics and I can't
appraise the economic history to be sure
I'm not an economist I might stumble I
make me make terrible mistakes here by
picking up conclusions that economists
but reputable ones have come to that may
not but probably still will be a big
festive fussed about as well happen in
scholarship after all this the way
things go but I mean in the economic
history alone is priceless for example
writings in recent times about the 1790s
about the launching of the economy of
the country or about the the coming of
progressive taxation in the first two
decades of the 20th century it's very
interesting or about the Great
Depression I want the what the various
folks are trying to do and what the
consequences likely were the politicians
and the institutions that were trying to
get the country out of a terrible plight
yes now there are I would say there are
there are in doing this there are there
are two general concerns of political
science that inform the project
political scientists not just about the
US but about about well in world in
general these we're going to switch this
light three yes one of them is is regime
stability and legitimacy as a concern a
major concern in political science after
all
and the in the end comparative politics
writing it's a fairly common theme that
separation of power systems that have
presidencies don't work all that well I
mean I'm referring here to probably the
premium writer in this vein as our
colleague one lens of some years ago
appointed Oh is a fan was one of
parliamentary systems pointing to the
unbalanced instability of residential
systems after all who would design
anything that way you just set things up
so people can fight with each other who
would want to do that now I realize
there are very good principal arguments
for setting up things so that
institutions that politicians check each
other that's not a question nonetheless
and they find the comparative literature
it's a fairly common point often what
some are sometimes it is expired that
that presidential separation of power
systems have got some vulnerabilities
but the American regime after all this
isn't so on at this point here the
American region has not been unstable
yes it was a civil war and you can't get
more unstable than that but it's a the
regime kicked back into place so to
speak in 1865 or maybe 1876 or sometime
after the Civil War and leaving aside
that this more than a hiccup look we did
that in school the American regime after
all has been extraordinarily stable I
mean it's a separation of powers regime
that goes way back at it looks to be to
me extraordinary stable today as a
separation of powers regime it's a it's
it's probably not more stable than the
British machine a different machine
British came in some respects probably
has changed more since 787 then as the
American regime but I think there's a
basic similarity between the two regimes
in there and this ability of course the
British regime is a parliamentary regime
it's but that's the that's the American
regime as a whole but take big Congress
by itself by itself oui oui
wait what are we grouse about we grouse
about the job performance that generally
is what produces the low ratings we
gross gross about the policies that come
out of council ill every grocery grouse
about the processes the filibuster and
so forth of the old committee system for
example the labeling out of pork and
such but the the basic institutional
arrangements don't seem to get groused
about that is even when's the last time
you went to lure rally wear something
wanted to get rid of Congress it doesn't
probably that probably doesn't happen I
mean if you take the the basic idea that
you've got Congress out there for one
thing and the presidency out there for
another and the courts out there for a
third it's sort of like the fish of the
water it's not notice that much and it's
not pet or hammered or attacked I mean
summer change I'm through all the
structures and some regimes are
vulnerable if you take the old French
Republic's or take for that matter the
British for dream right now they lost
Ireland another losing Scotland that's a
kind of instability in a regime but the
yeah the you know there it is it seems
to be there it is there it is and not
only that Congress itself although as I
say this continual criticism and the
respects that I talked about it or them
the criticisms it's it's own it's
congress in itself may press to the wall
if you ask the voters ask people out
there lacks mesitylene legitimacy is a
somewhat different question that is so I
go to a refer here to as my study that
was made in nineteen 2004-2005 by the
Annenberg Institute in Philadelphia
right the best idea I've seen of this
kind a very very deep study national
interviews
around and ask people their views of
institutions a lot of questions a lot of
questions and this is the this 405 by
the way that sub that's when Bush 43 was
president was just at the end of his
first in beginning of a second term
2004-2005 it's best to ask this kind of
a question if you're looking at Congress
and President assessments probably it is
anyway when one party controls both of
the institutions which the Republicans
did in 2004 2005 that then solve all
analytic problems but there it is and it
is what they got the this is 2000 again
republicans are running everything
asking loudly who should make the
decisions on basic matters policy should
it be Congress sure to be the president
or should it be bugged the answer was
Congress fifty-nine percent the
president 21-percent both fourteen
percent and I've seen there isn't any
consistent time series that dwells on
this questions as far as i know the john
deere boy mercer justice and i are
looking for more we found some some
pieces out the air in there but
generally what there is up there seems
to confirm this basic this basic
judgment but among off there if you ask
people that question you'll get an
answer something like that another
question they asked they asked voters to
choose and respondents to choose between
these two choices on the one had
legislative checks are gu x isn't as
interim checks and balances legislative
checks are good was one option the other
option was legislative checks because
whitlock and inaction ok suppose he had
that boon friday which one do you choose
the answer worth seventy percent truths
legislative checks are good twenty six
twenty one twenty percent she was so
true so let us say x close gridlock in
an action which is quite interesting as
a certain probably a certain shrewdness
out there about about these things i
think it's quite interesting so my first
again the first general concern here is
as regime stability and legitimacy which
i'm going to come back and hit
and the lecture a week from now on
Tuesday the toilet 29th I want to spend
maybe you know 20 or 25 minutes on that
question then after I goes through some
material that heads toward toward an
interpretation yes the second the second
general concern which does come up after
all people study regimes or the policies
that come out of regimes is comparative
performance of countries and taking
countries that whole there's a lot of
that and we routinely make performance
comparisons and it used to be the with
the Americans would there's a lot of
England envy here in the 19th century
then there was a lot of sweet and envy
about the 1950s 60s and 70s now there's
a lot of what's going on with China type
of consideration now as people think
think across countries here I want to I
want to wrangle or wangle Congress into
such comparative assessments and a basic
kind of question i'm aiming for is this
one a basic kind of question at the end
of the day this is what i'd like to
catch them custom elimination on is this
has the American welfare state or to put
it another way the American handling of
debts and deficits that's there in a
recent times or American imperial
expansion with been out there for a long
time has any of these things or any of
other certain other things that would
appear on a list there of this gauge
evolved in a distinctive way because of
the operations of Congress an evolved in
a distinctive way because of the
operations of Congress that is so it's
just as an imprint here by Congress on
the USA but also in comparative
effective of fearing the u.s. send them
in a way that other countries unbalanced
have not gotten Vader to whatever
reasons not to be sure this
it's difficult lighten up before the way
of the way I work at that is the
following is to make this kind of
comparison to make this kind of ahead to
make this kind of comparison the way
there is a following what exactly do I
want to look at my stick is to look at
certain prominent transnational impulses
what a save that have that have been out
there let us say during the last two in
one quarter centuries automatic other
metaphors for this might be in some
sense of rather though no metaphor is
perfect challenges or agendas they've
been out there in a and a and evolving
set of pure countries the French the
British the Germans and Japanese the set
of beer companies berries berries at
time but the laws of all comparisons can
be made across pure sets that at various
times so that's that's it now such a
course it's a to glom on to compel
impulses and there's a disrespect of it
225 years it has for me i hope i think
it has i hope it does have to utilities
for analysis to utilities one is success
it suggests what to look at it suggests
what to look at that is if something is
a big deal or a big thing a big agenda a
big challenge a big impulse to write a
whole lot of countries then maybe it's
worth looking at it's to operate that
way is this their clear a little bit
from what local isms secondly to proceed
it this way is to pave the way to
comparative assessments comparative a
performative assessments across
performance assessments across across
countries now in doing this the way i'm
thinking about it it's as a certain
galiyon flavor then is that i say that
because
I say that this is the image that this
is the alien flavor then among countries
that are communicating with a show that
which they are made the u.s. is not
alone there's so much insularity I think
in the American scholarship and the the
Congressional scholarship Oh history
does roll along in a set of orders
largely innocent of borders to a great
degree it poses or there come about
opportunities or imperatives or for fads
or whatever concerns agendas across
across borders as we as we roll to the
grow through time there are there is
aight Geist's there are contagions as we
roll as we roll for the centuries an
example of this would be a nun that this
will appear on my list as I go on the in
the late 19th century the question of
how to respond to the rise of industrial
capitalism in the late 19th century
which entails the coming of the
socialist bodies for example that's
clearly an instance of a something
that's happening it's part of the
contagion partly come a common
occurrence but they certainly
communication as the response to
capitalism comes abound that's there all
right impulses I go to one let me let me
be before getting to a list which I'm
going to do in a couple of had a few
minutes let me say this that I want to
ward off some misapprehensions before
getting into this I'm not exactly
looking at problem solving problem
solving that is problem solving seems to
be conscious of the idea of people
seeing a problem community or an
agreement seeing a problem and figuring
the way through a path of causation and
activity to a solution of the problem
sometimes what I'm going to be talking
about here is is characterized by that
but sometimes it's not I'd say more
accurately what I'm looking at is
as the is the end states the various
countries have tend to tend to arrive at
the antis states that they tended to
arrive at at various times on various
matters regardless of whether they got
there through what looks like problem
solving our open I'd intention that it's
how they were the end states how they
got there also I'm not kidding on are
expecting to find or give me making any
great making any great any great
importance out of a consensual policy
making it is so generally speaking
there's a lot of conflict and violence
in the American past consider the Civil
War for example in arriving at an end
state and said the Machiavelli Rob that
it's the nature of the public still to
exhibit conflict to engage in conflict
into to exhibit it and I think that's
mature of the American Republic as it's
it's gone through the even though it's a
stable regime that since a lot of Surat
at Etta conflict which came out openly
in the 1860s out of the road also I want
to say that as I go through these
patches of experiences impulses I'm not
clocking a trying to clock progress as
in the 19th century Whiggish sense you
know the Macaulay sense that at some
history is that is the progression which
is upward as it goes from bad to good as
we as we all become lonely as a British
liberalism sets in and becomes a
hegemonic now I'm using the term
performance here in a more neutral sense
as I'm using it performance a system or
congressional performance and some of
these enterprises or states of affairs
I'm going to talk about was quite
appalling quite a Pollock as we don't
have to look back and like what happened
in American history and then
important instances i think we don't
that's not that's not it I don't want to
one Telegraph the implication that doing
progress i'm doing progress and then in
that sense that i think the term
performance can be used naturally is a
fashion i'm using it here is what i came
up with this is a this is a table of 13
13 impulses each of which has a that is
a transnational location is in each case
i'm going to run through them briefly in
a moment you could see something
happening or being tried to be happening
and a range of peer countries at various
times in history is that it's and I I
took this very seriously I went into
history and comparative politics to take
a look and see what what was going on on
on out there as well as in the only in
the usa it's them and they they let me
go through it you see the time I have
timelines there which are roughly which
imply roughly to what I'm talking about
that they don't some of the lines of
longer than other lines you'll notice
that it's the horizontal lines covered
longer periods of history than do some
others at the base you see the years
that is the the chart starts just before
1800 you see the bottom of the dates at
the bottom can you read it from the back
is it okay oh what a shame can you it's
got them somebody want to move up some
people said yes I hope you can see him
it's got the goes it starts about 1790
1789
then it runs along the dates at the
bottom or 1818 50 1950 and 2000 there
have set a half century segments down
there at the bottom come the horizontal
lines dividing these into segments 3323
into an i terribly important for my
purposes here the launch of the new
nation now that was that was you know
that's the 1790s that may be the first
part 1787 through at least 1801 to go on
fire but I looked at they basically the
federalist period their continental
expansion by that i meant the he was
broadening out to absorb a large
proportion of the north american
contents on in the west and to the to
the south the mid-century consolidate i
mean by that the consolidation of the
National regime in the 1860s for the
Civil War a coming of a common
citizenship and though and rights across
citizens and an ideology of free labor
and free free both free citizenship
which became dominant if not exactly
hegemonic in the 1860s national state
was compelled to consolidate everybody
agrees on that but it's not singing
blitz in the USA at that time in the
19th century and I'm not going to make
the comparison serious one who would put
out these items building an industrial
economy in the late 19th century in the
early 20th century Taylor taming the
corporations and the rich by that I mean
I'm coming of the counterpoint to the
rise of capitalism in the European
socialist movements and the equivalents
in the USA rice the world power which
goes on forever maybe it's not going on
anymore maybe it's the opposite arise
these days but I start there after the
Civil War and this I mean I rise to a
remote part outside to north america
comment continent basically that's after
the mexican war and after they reach
evening reaching of the pacific coast
it's it's the rest of it since then
after alaska maybe to building a welfare
state that's it starts it's done maybe a
little before 1900 if you cut went to
add a civil war veterans pensions and
comes up to the president they both will
bow to prosperity which is I think a big
thing I've written a piece about that I
think it's important the civil rights
revolution after World War Two which is
immensely important and they late 40's
the 50s and 60s and it's not just an
American thing it's a transnational
thing thus leaking of the economy which
by that i mean the onset of
neoliberalism around in the 70s and 80s
deregulation tax-cutting weaker unions
the receding of Keynesian the formulas
and so on and then in very recent times
addressing climate cage and trying to
drive try to control that debts and
deficits all of these of these instances
have transnational correlates and in all
of them Congress is so is implicated
implicated I probably I probably by
athira bit in choosing instances where
is there's some interesting role for for
Congress some interesting role some
comments about this before right perhaps
dip into the first instance of it and I
can do that in order to do this I have
to deal with not with just good
congressional performance but
presidential performance after all I
mean it's it's a twosome it's a
threesome if you take the codes which
are not going on sidestepping the goods
which is a terrible thing to do but
doing it I'm looking at the elective
institutions and presidency and the
Congress but they so very much it has to
be a consideration of the imprint of the
presidency as well as in so far as the
imprints can be can be distinguished of
the of the Congress and I'm another
comment is I'm looking at the federal
government the some night interested in
the state local government or municipal
go down there don't do that it's not
here also I'm not taking up developments
or impulses or agendas that have located
chiefly of the society or in the economy
rather than having that an interesting
and perhaps very large role for the
federal government and maybe after
almost change in America happens in the
society and in the economy it's probably
a fair thing to say like the internet
revolution that doesn't have a place on
it lists very important but it's not a
government not a governmental thing or
changes and gender relations are largely
I think a societal thing because it's
not as if they don't have a governmental
decision making them in at all but it
seems to be very dominantly society of
evolution of societal standards on that
front I've gone here in this list of all
white on today it is a god I picked out
addressing climate change and control
like that and deficit because those
concerns do extend back quite a while a
couple of decades at least I'd say it's
possible I can get a handle on them also
to get a handle I know it's going on in
the u.s. compares with what's going on
in tier countries is good writing about
that as a fair amount of experience but
I've stayed clear of concerns that are
very present that don't have much
arc ya don't have much there to a finish
yet ticularly interested in Right today
doesn't make a prominent appearance here
except for these two concerns another
room I want to say that what I'm dealing
is I'm not trying to be exhaustive and
dealing in America this is highly
selective not oily but it's selective
coming back going back all those ways i
but it looks like its exhaustive and
insofar as it does map the histories or
try to bap the history what i'm doing
here is not i would say especially
orthodox that is it's not entirely i
know if the docs either but I've tried
I've I tend to bypass the conventional
chunking of American political history
into heroes that it said jacksonian here
was this the dealy or was that and so
forth that's so not really very much
interested in doing that I think the
some food here but i think the era
scholarship has gotten got a little bit
stale in recent times partly because
we've had more exists oracle experience
in recent decades but but also because
there's been there is so much history
writing writing of history that that
qualifies it was asked to resign or
asterisks on our raises questions about
the conventional chunking into these
eras also i think the theme the chunky
Lee writing a political history head has
been generally speaking it's been too
insular that is it hasn't people haven't
looked abroad that much to see what's
been going on in Carla countries that
might illuminate what's going on right
here I think it's very important to do
that by the way it's I don't think I
think that people who study American
politics American political history
should should should look elsewhere to
see let me give me an instance of that
this is off my what
but I'm just thinking about it because
I've got I'm going up to a conference in
toronto next week and it's about
somebody up there is putting together a
conference it looks at american
political development as well as
Canadian and British political
development that's trying to put the
three of them together today this idea
there is a field in the USA called
American political development of people
putting this conference together and
trying to generalize that into what AC
UK political development America Canada
UK political development which i think
is very interesting things to do and
it's a good idea I instance anecdote
coming up anecdote coming up at home
from reading that is it's about the it's
about the 1790s this its we all learned
in in school about the Alien and
Sedition Acts of terrible things may the
Alien and Sedition Acts passed in 1798
and we say good lord what did they do
that for I mean it's a violation of the
Fourth Amendment it's just terrible
stuff how could I may have done that it
seems like kind of a a demonic move from
outer space the Alien and Sedition Act
but terrible people must have done this
in 1798 well it turns out they're
passing very similar very similar
legislation at the same time in Canada
and Britain there it was I mean it's an
instance on a larger transnational
palate that's being exhibited in the
Alien and Sedition Acts and this was the
this the Poli onic boys are going on and
and the I mean the US was not directly
about but it almost went through what
with France the US and 1790
you know that it's almost a very bloody
war which is watered off the British
were fighting within with a friend and
in all these countries is a great deal
of anxiety about sedition and about
aliens because aliens might sound like
that Dave Barton sedition that's what
these piggly the Irish they add it into
the Irish there was so there it is
that's a perfect instance of to me
anyway of an illumination that can occur
by looking up looking out comparatively
that as I know do that till I read this
article at some journal while ago it's
fascinating I think all right they ate
what I'm doing to finish her off the
comments here I guess I want to put on
another yeah I just been saying these
things I don't have I don't and I am
dealing with these 13 impulses I I don't
do too much with the with the political
parties I I it's not my question what
did the parties do that if the parties
were out there but I'm interested in
what the government did or what people
in the government did that's it's a
little different that's a difference in
emphasis it is it to keep asking the
question what to the parties do in
American history is to untie remember
emphasize both of the institutions do
collectively and what the individuals
within them do and also to skimp on over
the history the very high component of
activity that's taken place across the
parties as cross-party prosperity
coalition's doing things it's a very
very common picture in American history
is quite quite interesting so now that's
it that's my that's my that's my
introduction actually my 13 instances
and I've run 61 in short I don't know
but maybe what I can do therefore it's
still one this alone is to eliminate the
first of the first instance the first
impulse there will be a teaser from next
time which is about they don't have
another room direct slide but next time
it's kind of crowded so it's not
and thing to swap over one of those
instances at this time we have to talk
about this 13 instances next time next
time it's going to be a rush of material
30-11 actually I left two of them I did
leave to it until the following to the
state which means not one that about
four and a half minutes for each impulse
which is not very much so I'm worrying
about crowding and there's a lot of
stuff there it's a lot of material so
there we are so let me say that first
one of these is its fingers over its of
next lecture but it's okay it'll be a
kind of a taste of the sort of analysis
of doing the launching of the American
state a nation in the 1790s when of
course it's a well-known story in very
many ways 78 87 the constitution of the
first Congress in 1789 and so on and
there is fit in comparison with with
other places as they the Latin American
Republic's most of the Latin American
Republic's came into existence pretty
quickly after did the American one the
Haitian Republican decade later the
Spanish Republic's a couple of decades
later much later the Brazil but there it
is it's a range of comparison also a
fair comparison is the although it comes
a bit later but still there's a lot of
commonality the Brit the other British
settlers states in many respects the
American the USA is just another British
suckler state I mean out there are
Canada Australia and New Zealand and in
some respects after all it's also a
Dutch settlers they South Africa they're
all out there so you mean they're
fitting comparisons out there so it was
South Africa aside it makes sense to
look as a comparative Paris to the sea
to look at the launch sending American
nation and state compared with these
other places it's fair and to talk about
performance in judgment and so on there
it is you know it's fair that's the
comparison said the pure country said
don't have a slide for that yet because
I'm think are going over to next time
but we don't all right all right now the
story in that right now it seems to me
that one story has become well known the
other story i'm going to make up myself
is that if you look at the look at the
executive branch is extremely important
at that time
and Alexander Hamilton is extremely
important there's a lot of agency in
history after all right Alexander
Hamlin's come into his own in the
history recently about they're going to
take his face off one of those bills I
guess maybe they are which is at the
tanner that's funny I forgotten but all
that having been said we got a musical
out there called Hamilton and now in
bright away you know we don't have one
called Madison and one called Jefferson
we've got a Broadway show called
Hamilton which in Hamilton which may be
indicative of something in the brother
at least correlates with the
considerable a claw esteem that is
rained down on Hamilton as the as the
builder of the American economy in the
1790s 1790 through whenever we go to
power and 1796 in philly quites
appraising one of the one of the
important maestro's of the history of
finance and anywhere you know a preface
a style setter mean the debt the dealing
with the dealing with at bringing in the
bank even having something to do with
the founding of the the stock exchange
on Wall Street 1792 presiding over a
fiscal crisis in 1792 bringing into
effect the Coast Guard they didn't do
that noted that watch the smugglers a
rusty couldn't collect the tariff money
all that is there that's that that's on
Herman Hamilton's blotter is quite
interesting and it correlates with and a
South sales tax problem it's really
quite something that's executive
performance that's in the 1790s so you
might ask why why is Congress there at
all it isn't even important to look at
Congress in the 1790s but well here's a
story on that once you have what I'm
interested in is the is the is the end
state as not necessarily in people's
attention since they go about things so
with Alexander Hamilton you have an
awful lot of intention that's not in
question but it seems to be the story
for Congress in the seventh the first
decade and a half or so is in this place
and to one of the seems I'm dealing in
here is in in in in a solidification and
it helps to solidify the legitimacy the
American regime with the public now the
party's did that to the coming in the
party system did that but you know these
Federalists amel turn on the rest they
were a little short on legitimacy
seeking they could be testing and they
could be troublesome and they could be
unpopular you know you can see the whole
country falling apart
by 1800 or so given just those
Federalists you can see it but the on
Capitol Hill at least these things
happen for one thing it was Capitol Hill
the Congress had brought in the Bill of
Rights it's one of the first things they
did on to Hamilton's Beck and seventeen
ninety i think it was right there it was
it's developed on capital it was you
know that was a equilibrate ur that's
what the people who didn't like the
Constitution wanted to remember that in
the Bill of Rights also Congress brought
into effect in the mid 1790s if the Ways
and Means Committee and a process of
fiscal economic checking and balancing
with the creation of the Ways and Means
Committee that's very important it's an
it goes on through American history it
sets up a centre of expertise on Capitol
Hill which came to be invested pretty
quickly by Albert Gallatin it was a
major financial expert on the
Jeffersonian Madisonian side to check to
counterbalance to do things against to
criticize to make accountable whatever
the Federalists are doing in the fist
that was important also another thing
that is a recent scholarship tits little
it's been then I found more interesting
in the and this writing of those times
you see the scholarship you've also and
I would say a student people didn't talk
about this very much but now we've had
an escalation and efflorescence is made
with my sleeves of writing about the
1790s and I a greater greater greater
and greater importance assisted me in
the sculptures that being assigned to
the jay treaty I'm have even heard of
that one this was a treaty brought about
by George Washington and sent to the
Congress in the mid 1790s which solves
some problems with the British and
opened up the u.s. got the u.s. packet
of the British trading area into the
British trading area which was very
basic I mean for the economic evolution
of the country getting new West back
into the British trading area as I
understand it was basic and it was
fussing about death of his opposition
the story the Congressional story is
this that is a full book about this
recently that is the the Senate ratified
it by two-thirds which sometimes happens
with treaties but it needed money it had
to do it and it needed sanction on the
house had to approve the thing the house
said to approve but they have the proof
of my majority vote that's all it took
in the house to approve this thing other
is no day treated going into effect they
fight about that for months I mean that
was this is a great exercise in fussing
on Capitol Hill for eight months and in
mobilization of public opinion around
the country made out on the frontier
they're talking about the Jay Treaty
Pittsburgh that area in the mid seventy
nine very interesting I mean they what
happened finally wasn't they approve the
thing by I think that one or two votes
in the house with the majority party in
the house which is the Republicans at
that time that's a medicine he
Republicans that is getting rolled as we
talk about it right now your majority in
the party house when they lose it always
say they got rolled somehow so the
federal is the administration plus they
will but bring him out or participating
in bringing about a cross-party majority
brought this into the fact that the
story of that I think what happened this
very boy because at that time you
couldn't tell how national palace was
caught it was going to perkel on you
could know I was going to work out it
wasn't clear that participation in
politics was legitimate it wasn't clear
that opposition was legitimate it wasn't
clear what these institutions would be
doing or should be doing so he was a
great exercise in doing something by
fussing and the other side had to learn
how to lose it's very important when
your opposition learns how to lose
nothing's more important than politics
probably than that I mean ended when you
lose when you went with what when you
lose in a roll call vote that's pretty
solid rooted in public opinion pretty
much you just have to put your tail
between your legs and go back go back
home and that's pretty much what
happened this instance we didn't hear
about the matter after 1796 is goes that
are interesting incidents finally with
the Congress in 1801 the remember there
was effects contested election worse
than bush worse than bush Gore in so in
1800 it had not happened before I think
far as I know people say this that a
government in a bit of a switch from one
party to another here or elsewhere has
the direct consequence of an election
that's I think correct commonly said I
don't know if there's a British Jensen
probably not a clear British instance
they but you remember it ended up a mess
because the Electoral College is a mess
we all learned this from near 11 i'm not
going to rehearse the facts about it we
learned this indeed the Jeffersonian
seem to have Jeffersonian him being the
candidate of the opposition party at
that time they seem to have an edge and
they in the vote and actually this
recent study about voting in calendar
1800 all the way down from top to bottom
in the country you know the local
elections of state election state
legislation blah blah blah and the
judgment is that that year the
difference only Republicans they
probably got about fifty two percent of
the vote which is roughly what the Obama
Democrats got you know in 2012 not much
but it's there it's pretty indecisive
but still in the the whole business
ended up a mass on Capitol Hill and the
house had to decided and they decided to
fund some house a very messy business
with a cross-party coalition and the
winter of 1801 with some Federalist
finally joining with the Madisonian
Jefferson Republican still to pole-vault
Jefferson into the White House and there
are counter scenarios in which they
wouldn't have done that and would have
been worse best I'll stop with that
that's my first census for next time but
that's okay that we got into that we
want to do cuil an a for a while now
don't we soon you want to come up and
manage how we don't do that one how are
we going to I don't know how I don't
know I don't have a clear maybe you
don't need to come up I don't know the
answer to what do you think
because it's important that we do this
because I'm getting deaf so if you ask
something I won't hear it that's so this
important reason yes I'm here you for
the mic can thank you very much for this
talk and I wondered whether in your
timeline I think I understand why you
excluded the Progressive Era that was
basically among some states I don't
quite understand work I don't see
anywhere on there a development that
Congress has been involved in and which
is emanated in a situation that is now
widely commented namely the degree of
inequality in the country the decline of
the middle class it seems to me that you
couldn't possibly begin to explain that
without bringing Congress into the
picture somehow you talk about sleeping
yeah or the sleeping which of course
some people would give another title to
a date of course I made up that term by
the way I think I did by the way the
Progressive Era I don't have a I don't
have an exact desk designation for that
but what I deal with that is centered
and what we call a progressive era which
is unclear boundary some people goes
back to 18 19 and some you know their
ative is the reaction to the rise of
industrial capitalism and I want to talk
about bring in a regime of regulation
and progressive taxation and Congress is
I didn't principally responsible for
that for that both of those things very
important very important very important
i mean the the the development of stiff
progressive taxation in the first two
decades of the 20th century is
dominantly and it's very stiff it was I
mean the US was the world leader in
progressive taxation apparently
according to bacchetti anyway in the
early 20th century and a congress had
heavier rounds on the switch on that one
that did the president so I'm going to
talk about that next time is very
employed yeah but there's no there's no
out there now there's no passionate
support for going after the ridge the
way that was in the first two decades of
the 20th century it's just not there in
American society right now responsible
for this and I don't see that reflected
in the best bank with this being for the
state of public opinion the tax code
well but no I don't think that's true
either i mean the tax comes down I mean
attacks of the height bracket taxes I
mean Kennedy brings the I brackets
highest bracket tax down from what 71
percent it's 91 % to seventy percent
Reagan presses it from 72 down to fifty
percent is and a congressional thing Joe
you can't say thats dominantly a
congressional thing I'm talking about
I'm talking about what makes it possible
in our tax code which must the
amendments take place in Congress to
that code it isn't the executive that
changes the code it's congress and if
you think in terms of who in fact can
use the code for for their own purposes
let me give you an example it seems to
me the congress is responsible for hedge
fund manager
we can take a chunk of their salary and
not call it income but call it something
else now Congress call it interest
carried forward that's part of what the
regime currently looks I agree with all
that Joe I think that that's quite right
i mean it goes back to the 19th century
and it has its precedent and the way
they used to put together the tariff
bills in the 19th century there will be
collections of particular ism which
carried over into particular isms in the
tax code in the 20th century and today
that's quite right however the the
that's quite right but the the Congress
does traffic in those things no question
about it a tax taxes after tax code but
if you're interested in the something
else which is a little different which I
did bring up the program progressivity
in the sense of taking money away from
the rich why that I mean that's pretty
much a product of wars show parties
don't do that worse than that what's up
I'm interested in how the United States
has managed to become the leader among
developed industrial countries in both
the degree of inequality economically
speaking and the rate at which
inequality is increasing in this country
if you if you don't involve Congress in
that I have a simple question who did it
well I think Congress is involved and
they in the end the tax breaks Tamina
putting two go together over a long
period of time it's attack brake system
if we compared with systems in other
countries that's quite right a small
stuff which can add up to pretty big
otherwise I don't know where you're
talking about I don't see what Congress
is responsible for what you're talking
about otherwise you mean to tell me that
you would the United States Congress
with how income is district distributed
well I've already everybody I've already
put it out in the sense that I put it
out there that i did but i also am
claiming that the that the big tax cuts
have Cubs substantially the behest of
the presidency with Bush 43 as well as
with Reagan as well as with Kennedy all
those things and those came down from a
high level of Taxation which was largely
World War two in the Korean War it's not
surprising insta came down yeah the
sleeping of the economy's very
intriguing impulse I was surprised that
you put that you know stop around 2,000
to the sleek name of the economy why
would you I would think why why would I
do what put a stop to to sleek inning oh
I see I see where i put another to see
where i put it let's see where I point I
think it's ongoing well that's quite
possible where did I stop at 2,000 I
could have put it at two thousand and
yeah 2003 maybe but I think in the last
decade is not a lot is there I mean the
stuff I'm talking about I'm talking
about deregulation tax cuts at me and
the big tax cut Stella to the islands
random short there and with business tax
cuts in 2003 personal in 2001
deregulation we have you know i don't i
just don't see it i mean the congress's
and I've been doing things they didn't
really weaken unions or I'd say I'm it's
really i don't see an under obama or
under like bush it's going on for a long
time but the thrust of it i think it's
certainly the thrust of its earlier yeah
i think so but anyway it's a contestable
point yeah yeah your your delivery is so
clear and good that's not earth since
I've been to lectures at Yale and I know
that's gratuitous what I'm saying it is
wonderful I do have a question on you're
saying we're not looking for solutions
here so while it's early i should say i
wish you could explain the development
of the extreme pragmatism where
everybody in each of the two parties is
beholden to the leader of the party
which has paralyzed
Congress right now you're talking about
here is as example well that's good
question and that's the development of
the last on third 30 years or so
actually it's a it's a reversion to the
pattern American history obtained most
of the time until the 1950s oh it's not
unusual I mean now the Holden's of the
leader may be putting a little strongly
but let's say the cohesion of the two
parties in Congress on either side was
very strong most of the time until
roughly the 1950s the exception is the
19 late 40s 1950s 60s and 70s that's
really exceptional American history for
the respective of a week party
leadership and cross party voting that's
quite right there but now recently yes
it has happened that way I think I mean
one very particular explanation of it
has to do which we know about is that
the the South mean the the the South
southern conservatives say Democrats
used to be you know a cross-sectional
Friday with a big Dixiecrat element and
the voters down there is did the
politicians and the change of the south
SF as help to sort the voters as well
the politicians in tomorrow more or less
cohesive blocks and when you get a
cohesive block on Capitol Hill a bar
cohesive rock it's easier to it's easier
than otherwise it would be to bring
about an operative logic where in power
is conceded to a leader or to a
leadership core as if you get an army
all facing in the same direction then
it's easier to have a general you want
to have at the top of it if your army is
just cacophonous then they may not want
to have a general with much power
what I want anybody would want you know
I that's it it's also out there in the
public eye being there a lot of
explanations for this i mean the public
is polarized media had a polarizing been
polarizing for us all those things of
truth and any of there's a rat for
political science and a political
sciences and all that influential but
it's now being commonly said that the
political scientists have brought about
this doctrine of responsible party
government in the 1950s of making a
terrible mistake that is having cohesive
parties the strong leadership on Capitol
Hill just doesn't comport very well be
the basic sinuous of the American
separation power system I did I just
finished reading a book manuscript by a
major political science author in which
he makes the case well we ought to have
the parties more divided they should be
people should be sorted less clearly
between Democrats Republicans we'd be
better off if that were the case that
goes back to the 1960s maybe that's true
that's part of an answer anyway it's a
tough one someone yell and look it's
interesting that I mean the leaders yeah
you say they're members of the Congress
are willing to concede or something like
that you said power to the leaders but
maisha tell John Boehner about that he's
having trouble after all of his troops
my wife loves it I can't stand it well
there we are may there it is that's what
Congress is like this division see let's
say it's a difficult matter I mean John
Boehner I mean they on Capitol Hill mate
I think they're American Republican
Party in the Congress right now is
something like an awful lot of major
parties across the world are now either
they're being becoming eternally divided
or they're losing voters to see session
parties that has taking them away from
love I mean it's true and France is true
and it written as tribute so as well
that's quite common through Greece well
so God just bill back to go
I want to ask you about can you hear me
about what can you hear me yes I got
okay I want to ask you about imprint so
right yeah sure so we have we have two
powerful players with the President and
we have the Congress yeah so presumably
each one of them will have an imprint
right I mean it's got presumably each
one will have an infrared usually that's
a character yeah I mean just in an
abstract way yeah so is there something
particular about the Congress that as
you look through you and this getting
ahead of it but but before we get
started is there something particular
about the Congress that describes its
imprint for example that its regional
that it's the wisdom or the folly of a
crowd that it's divided or non divided
as opposed to the president who's
presumably one person well we're going
to see a lot of that I hope next two
lectures are going to do a fair amount
of that but yes first of all the let me
say a little bit about imprint that is
often they often the relation between
the Congress and the president and some
policy area or some agenda area is
content ative or conflictual or
conflicted that's one wants a and the
other ones beach and they find out you
know it's fairly common but sometimes
that's not really what's going on
sometimes the the president will want
one with deal and one traffic and one
kind of activity and the Congress will
traffic and another kind of activity and
they're not exactly competitive with
each other they just sort of do
different kinds of things that's true
too but onto the body of your question
there yes I mean they I think that I got
to talk about this by the way it's a
very basic question that is the I think
that with the Congress they they well
what I mean one very clear thing to say
isn't their collective and they are
there 535 folks
institutions we teach with a
constituency and adding up to some
pattern of representativeness that's
basic that just gives you a different
picture from the president who some
who's one person and and I can have as
sticks into his things where is that
with Congress is always the case that
they have they have some how to
accommodate or to stare down or to voc
down or to fuss with a cacophony with a
with a variety of people that that's it
so this you would expect with that that
the in some sense is there you'd get
more more constancy on Capitol Hill on
then you will with the presidency we'd
also expect that you will probably get
less action on Capitol well then with
the presidency being that it's difficult
to get people together and do things on
council my own I think that's all
incorrect all that's correct I think
that one of the one of the was one of
the contributions that Congress makes to
the stability the system is to is to
make it somewhat hard to do things that
is it's it's it's hard for one crowd to
shut down another crowd and just put
them out of business it's just hard this
up it's hard to believe that these days
what would but look at the Congress
right now I mean the Republicans can't
get what they want out of Congress they
just can't and the Democrats kind of get
the day one out of Congress either there
it is too so it's so so it's an
interesting juxtaposition as I go
through these 13 we're going to find I'm
going to talk about the juxtaposition as
it's played out various ways I mean look
with look at the 1790s with Hamilton
Hamilton they power is centered in the
Treasury Department and it's very
important it's a point source kind of
thing well you could have somebody who's
very smart with a lot of expertise take
the lead and annex be extremely
consequential it's time for Congress to
do that kind of thing obviously whereas
on Capitol Hill it was they when it was
the it was the division the fabric as a
person as the rioting on double held it
allowed it to one to play this role that
I've
talked about as contributing to
legitimacy by the way as the as the
members of Congress are operating at the
1790s or 1801 they weren't getting up in
the morning and saying what can I do
today that makes assistant more
legitimate they just weren't doing
rather they were doing things i think
that contributed to the end state of
supplying a certain systemic legitimate
legitimacy by the early 19th century
it's a somewhat different points there
David Mike my question is also about
imprints and I'm about which imprint
yeah okay and if if I if I understand
you correctly you don't want it at one
of their gambling I you don't want to
make judgments about performance I don't
have a normative judgments who have your
phone I want to make judgments about the
effectiveness in performance probably by
the standards of the time yes well okay
so I'm kind of curious about how one can
avoid doing that but in any way so a
little history you might want to say to
build the building of the welfare start
starts in 1790s with its a Hamilton job
it was the creation of the u.s. Marine
and hospital service yea which was a
well welfare for John merchant merchant
sailors and and it was a nation building
economy building thing that Hamilton was
about is because there was a shortage of
labour force for sailors and they wanted
to attract sailors from abroad and take
care of them their health and take care
their families so you know in Merchant
Marine was that you know it's more
Hamilton for you yeah it's Hamilton so
so it created this what's the the
beginnings of the US Public Health
Service um but it also meant that we
didn't get a national Department of
Health until nineteen fifty three okay
and and the what's behind that was well
at the turn of the century you had
presidents Taft's Roosevelt Wilson they
all were on board with creating a
Department of Health a national
of health and and and progressive
elements in both Democratic Party in the
Republican Party were for it made total
sense typhoid didn't respect state lines
you know typhoid rivers from one city to
another state so there were all sorts of
reasons that it was an all a whole bunch
of health aspect things were done
scattered all over the bureaucracy
bureaucracy so so that the the head of
the marine hospital service obstructed
using Congress you know a network of
built the opposition it was vicious
bureaucratic infighting which drove the
Reformers crazy and it and admit that
for many you know many years we had no
sent you know National Public Health
Service and it so I'm one of those
liberals who see Congress as as a
perpetually obstructive force in the way
of rational public policymaking and I'm
wondering to what extent I guess how can
you avoid making those kinds of well i'm
going to make exactly that point about
building a national bureaucracies i
think congress has been larger and
obstructive i think that's an important
part of the picture of the American
welfare saying it has done a going
practice I guess that makes sense and if
the Hamilton in the Merchant Marine so
but i'm thinking i guess if they don't
know what I'm thinking I'm thinking of
the way oh yeah it gets like a really
big expensive thing with a veterans
pensions especially after 88 90 and then
it goes off at the time but yes I do
think that's right the missus mean this
is your feta Scotch ball case and I
think that's scar running that's
basically correct that basically correct
I think the Congress said there yeah
especially in the nineteen late 19th
century early 20th they they were not
good at building and sustaining and
financing public bureaucracies quite
right quite right it's a basic fear
that's a congressional
I think that's quite right they not only
that they are part of the question thing
is they are going to say this my third
lecture they they get a public agency or
a program going and they won't leave it
alone they won't leave it alone I mean I
remember was that method earth day she's
writing about Social Security over the
Social Security program over about I
forgotten what she says exactly but over
50 years they made something like 80
changes and the way the program operates
it's very difficult with the inconstancy
like that to operate inefficient
bureaucracy so yeah I think that's quite
right not only that the creation of
agency just plain the creation you can
see a difference between President and
Congress there which might probably
apply sometimes your president is easy
to ask for a cabinet department or
agency to be created a sort of like
putting on a press release and
presidents like to do that sort of thing
where'd you get uncomfortable hill and
there'll be all kinds of contributions
to log jams on a matter of creating a
new agency for one thing there are
already probably bureaucrats there who
don't want to be displaced and it will
be fought on Capitol Hill so I think
you'll find over a period of time our
presidents want their departments or
agencies it takes quite a while to grind
them through Congress and often it just
doesn't work some time to take decades I
think that's a feature I think that's
right
thank you